pour nantes autrefois n'est fait pour
les nantais le xvème siècle est une
époque qui a compté c'est le duc
françois ii qui donne à la ville sa
première université c'est le mariage de
la duchesse anne avec charlot 8 qui
scellant l'union de la bretagne et la
france lui apporta la paix à laquelle
elle rêvait c'est précisément dans un
des rares vestiges de ce 15ème siècle
que se trouve installé aujourd'hui le
syndicat d'initiative de nantes dont la
mission est triple accueillir documenté
et promouvoir
je vais vous prochainement invités mais
j'aimerais avoir un problème de
renseignement d'avouer une documentation
sur la vie oui certainement je vous
donne également une maquette que nous
avons édité à l'attention des personnes
qui s'installent à man la zone est
absolument tout renseignement vous est
il depuis les df gaz de france service
des eaux faire tout ce qui fait vous
savez à vous installer les écoles les
banquiers ni vraiment où enfin tous ceux
dont vous avez besoin pour une
installation à nantes
autrement profondeur de désemplir si
allah vous avez naturellement là
rouen normal qu'ils sont les étudiants
qui accepte les enfants soient
directement accueilli renseignements oui
mais aussi organisation de congrès
hébergement tourisme nautique social
industriel universitaire est entendu que
le touriste ne se bornent plus à
regarder les monuments à admirer les
sites à visiter les musées mais qu'il
veut connaître les possibilités du
commerce le potentiel de l'industrie en
un mot les activités de la région qu'ils
traversent
cette année nous avons reçu leurs
échanges trente mille visiteurs sont
venus en plus nous avons expédié 149
renseignement le document est déjà le
bassin pendant questions posées
mais elles sont d'ailleurs innombrables
et très variée
on nous demandait mais je crois que nous
pouvons encore faire face à plus de
demandes nous atteignons la place royale
grands ensembles du xviiie remarquer que
tous les immeubles sont absolument
identiques et ont été conçus de cette
manière afin de mettre en relief le
motif central
comment concevez-vous de 5 à 17 10 2009
5 81 ou
ou même plus tard
bien s'ils voulaient
le syndicaliste est en lui-même enfin
que le nôtre puisqu'il sait que la bière
est là ils veulent mais certainement
puisqu'il se trouve au centre en tant
que métropole d'équilibré trouve au
centre d'une vaste région
c'est donc un regroupement le mot est à
la mode auquel nous allons assister
parmi l'ensemble des syndicats
d'initiative
certains seront promues
une classification important et
serviront d'antenne de regroupement pour
tous les autres contrairement à ce que
l'on croit d'ordinaire qui surmonte
cette fronde ne représente pas la loire
nantes des marine armée de son trident
arrosé par la loire et ses affluents la
femme assise donnant les deux chattes de
chaque goutte et se trouve être la loire
et c'est face à la récré billon
si d'un côté
on panique
et pour de poser corps
à mener
dans la région on peut de son côté salé
galicienne
puisses sur le plan des loisirs plus
prisme
de manière d
pouvoir aussi proposé par y était
capable
c'était l'intérêt complet la région nous
allons attendre maintenant la rue
crébillon crébillon était un écrivain du
xviie siècle assez peu connu à récré
millions est une affaire des plus
commerçante de l'asile boutique de jute
tout de suite sur votre gauche vous
pouvez admirer l'entrée du passage
pommeraye ensemble des dix neuvième
passage collègues joie la récré millions
à la rue de la fosse
l'amour du passé n'est pas incompatible
avec les exigences de la vie moderne
prendre conscience de ces exigences sans
renier l'histoire n'est ce pas en
définitive le meilleur moyen de préparer
l'avenir